>>TE HOUSENG NGPRID IENOF FIRIND
CALLING FRIOIS
THE DOCTOR, ACCORDINGURCES.
AS SAITSFO FAI' LFENSETH OP' SPI
INE O
YESTEROL
HED THAIV BEEN SAVED IFER
T AND STAY
MEASURES INEIAL.
>> Reporter: THE WNOW DT DR. AN
IT FORIN A STATEMENT TODAY, WHIA
"RIDAIDTRUMP IS NG DFAUCI.
BUT
THMEDIA, THE
SPECULN.RUMP RETWEETED THIS
POST FROM A
CO TDED THESE F S: FA EARLIER,
DISEASE SPE
ACKNOWLEDGED TO CNN'S JAKE  THU
IFOUAD PROCESS THAT WAS
GO STARTEDON YOU COULD
HAVE SAVED SLY GOING T AT Repor
YORK TIMES" T DOCUMENTE
O WHILE TRUMPRAISED
FAUCE HAS PRIVAT
THAT OFTENAND HED TO
HIM QUESTIONS.
FAUCI H FRITICISM FROMME TRUMP
ONS BEFEENRS IN LATE JANUARY."NN
FOD SQUANDEREDHE
THOSE RESTRGHTOGHER MEASURES IN
U.S.>> DANGEROUS FOREI
TRAVTEH
OF OUR PEOPLEEEARLY FAR EARLIER
>> R Y SAYSENMP TOOSE SCING MEAK
HIS TOP HEALTH OFFICIALS
COMES ASSGN
RECOTRHE WEDM, NOT THE GO
HETWEETED, OMAKERE THAT IECISIOA
PRATES
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERN BE FULLY"
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT T WN
SHUTTING THE WOULD LEA TE
UH LIKEROTHE STANING ANDI LIKE
VEITUTIO
>> Reporter: E
PRESIDENT'SLLIES ARE NOWNTINUI
CRIT I
ANDYGS WHO ISOW CHAIR OF FREEDO
TO HE BELIEVESR.
HAS EMASCULATED THE EMYO
SAE, I THINK IT'S TIMFOR H TO M.
>>UH-HUHTL MUCH.
>>> REPUBLICANSARING F AUSINESSE
REPUBLICAN SOLUTIONO
BILLOCOL ONNG
MORE MONEY PR
SE A BIL
MORE MONEY FOR STATES AND
SP PS,TO FUND TESTING F
JOINENNINSOR JULIAEY.
JULIA, LET START W
QUESTION, DNOW IF
ANSWER EVEN EXISRAM,
PATE HAS DRSEBUSINESSMEN AND BU
FROMNDING,
ND THEINREON THE T I APPROVAL F.
RAINT AN DOESN
HOWEVER.
>> OF BUT I OUUBARENG TO
RUN OUT THI AND ONL $ION$350AS
OT ABLECH SMALLHYTH WERERU THIS
CONS
>> THIS IS BEYOND RE.
I SPOKEEF OBU KAR SAIVENA
CA20 OF SMALL
NE HERE COULD WE'RELION SLLIM J.
MORE CAS I REQUIRED, JAKE.
SADNCYMBANKS, BUT
AS O LAST WEEKEND, ILD,EYET
EMERGENCY LOANSTHANS, PAYPAL AN.
>> I THI COUEKEY.THESE FINTECH .
THEY T LENDMALLERHO
FIVE PLOYEES.
SO IS OFTHETHY,
THIS
GER.
THAT'S THE GOOWS.ILL HL
TH S BS
MIWELL.
SO AI  HERE,NGOUT E
UTION THAT